when it comes to the problem of quantum
gravity or theories of everything or
grand unified theories do you think that
what's missing is a whole conceptual
paradigm shift or is it just it's a
mathematical complication it can be
solved
without changing our view of what
reality is much
like what do you think is holding us
back which one is it
i think there's nothing holding back i
think we have theories of quantum
gravity and that might be right um
so we don't need to go look for new
ideas in quantum gravity we have to we
go we have to go try to figure out if
the idea is we have a good or bad
um i think this idea that oh quantum
gravity is such a mystery that we need
some new idea why do we need some new
idea i mean we have theories the reason
we're not sure is that we cannot test
them not because they're wrong or
they're bad
group point of gravity is one i don't
want to say this is the right theory
because it might be wrong theory might
another one may be right
or maybe we haven't yet you know
understood the relation between this or
maybe i mean i have reasons to think
that string thing is not good and group
quantum gravity is good but
for quantum gravity itself we have
decent theories of the the missing staff
the piece pieces we don't understand
well
but i don't
share this idea oh my god we're missing
a big idea we're not missing a big idea
to
articulate something like loop quantum
gravity you need a big conceptual shift
because there's no background space no
background time as i said before you
have to accept the idea that the
fundamental shape of the world you don't
use the time variable so it's already
there it has been worked out is is
decades of discussions
that have come out with a a possible
story
we have more than one possible stories
because there are other
possible alternatives it's you know
symptomatic safety the string theory and
and and others
uh but we have theories about quantum
gravity what we miss
is you know filling up details
you know look what it's hard to do
calculations of scattering string
theories how to understand how to come
down four dimensions nobody really has
done it yet
uh the you know the schemes ideas but
nobody goes from the big theory down to
the to the standard model
um
i i would not look for other
why should we look for other ideas then
we just you know put them in a drawer
and we don't know how to
we need
smart ideas for checking those theories
and and that's what many people are
doing working on black holes working on
early universe trying to see if some of
the theories we have can be tested
just so you know that question was from
dong-hyun yoon i just wanted to make
sure to say that and the last last
question is craig reed tcr i'd be
curious to know what he thinks of nema
arkani hameds amplituhidron and his
lecturer on the end of space time i
don't think i've ever heard rovelli
comment on it
lima is great um it's uh
it's it's a powerful thinker it's a
great mathematician i had uh
i remember a very good uh uh afternoon
in princeton talking with him
um
i
there's a book that just came out
um which is a
big thick book with interviews of people
in uh
quantum gravity
uh of all different
uh
i can just look it up if you give me a
keyword so i can tell the audience what
it is if it is sitting here let me go
get it yeah great
conversations on quantum gravity
wonderful
edited by
jacob armas a-r-m-a-s
and uh it's it's a big thick book um
of interviews
detailed interviews of uh
a large uh number of people um
doing quantum gravity it's a bit boring
because it's a big thing with everybody
you know same question so
to but i'm going systematically through
it and reading all of it uh because i'm
curious to actually know what the
various people and it's remarkable
they're very
diverse ideas
and i read the uh the one of nina uh
academic uh in in detail of course um
because his alphabetical order
is the first
um i'm just almost halfway past halfway
through the book
and
so i'm i'm thinking
while reading the various uh
people i'm curious to know what all the
people think i'm i'm reading and of
course i'm
i'm checking what they say with respect
to what i think and i'm trying to get
the ideas that i don't know and trying
to argue
uh so it's a very good exercise for me
um
now
i think that uh
he belongs to um
that
uh
part of the community
who um has fell in love with the uh
maldecinna idea of the bulk boundary
and then later on has given
a sort of an ideological basis on that
um by an argument
that says that uh in quantum gravity
we have to go to infinity
uh to uh to define the theory
because there are physical reasons
for which we cannot make a measurement
in the bulk so to say so all the actual
measurements are uh
and uh in fact in the book he articulate
that because this is good because he
he explains his you know his deep
motivations for doing that
now i'm convinced that this argument is
wrong
um
uh
because it presupposes the space time
and uh
because it
it it mixes
the need for the coherence for making
measurement with the the distance in
space so they i think it's technically
wrong
and uh but this is has become a dogma in
in his word especially in princeton
um
that you can only describe things from
uh from a very large distance from a
synthotic distance
uh so he's going entirely in that
direction
and that's why he doesn't think that
loop quantum gravity might work because
root cultivarity is a description of
quantum space time locally in in a small
region so i'm i'm here
i i make an experiment a quantum
experiment and i compute what comes out
without need to go to a centopia
um
so uh
you know these people are going doing
technical work but that's the assumption
uh on which also his work on the on the
um
scattering amplitudes
it's good but it's not
it's not in the four-dimensional
generativistic world in which we live so
uh i i don't think there's a solution of
quantum gravity and the property of
quantum gravity
is in fancy mathematics
um
i think it's in just writing things
properly i mean there's a look on the
right it defines scattering amplitudes
they're very hard to compute
but they're there
and
does that without going to the boundary
inside space-time
and the
objection he has to look onto gravity i
think they're they're wrong i wish we
could you know with all these people i
wish we could sit down
and uh
maybe i'm arrogant but i think i could
convince them that some of the
assumptions that they are wrong
of course some of the senses i may have
are wrong and i wish they could tell me
why